welcome to protests
the prospect for political change I'm
Elise Giuliano a visiting professor of
political science here at Barnard and
Harmon Institute and we have a very
distinguished panel today here to talk
to you about a very dynamic and exciting
time in Russian politics not that
Russian politics isn't always dynamic
and exciting but even more so since
December so I'm just going to without
further ado introduce the panelists and
then we're going to have a presentation
briefly from each speaker and then we'd
like to open it up to question and
answers okay so first the first speaker
today will be Tim fry the director of
Herman instituted a professor of
political science here at Columbia
University he is most recently the
author of the award-winning book
building states and markets after
communism the perils of polarized
bureaucracy of democracy the perils of
polarized democracy the book was
published by Cambridge in 2010 and it
recently won the triple a double s so a
C's excuse me is a new title is a
different acronym the ed would award so
we're I'm happy to congratulate him for
that achievement the next speaker is
also well known to Columbia University
audiences Steve insist on ova CH who is
the Catherine and Shelby column Davis
professor at ciba he also worked from
the late 90s to 2001 as ambassador at
large and special adviser to the
Secretary of State on the new new
independent states he's also the author
of many volumes and articles that I'm
sure many of us have read and I'd also
finally like to welcome Lincoln Mitchell
who is associate reached research
scholar and associated adjunct professor
here at harriman Institute Lincoln has
worked in the field for the National
Democratic Institute in Georgia
and as a specialist on political
campaigns and as a result became a
specialist on George and politics and on
US democracy promotion in the region in
the former Soviet Union his most recent
book is forthcoming with university of
pennsylvania press in march 2012 and the
name of that book something I look for
is the color revolutions with that I'd
like to turn the microphone over to Jim
Frey thanks a lot of these okay i think
the we hope to have a very robust
discussion today with that in mind i'll
briefly lay out some thoughts about the
parliamentary elections the protests and
the future of Russian politics after the
March for the presidential elections a
cedar sauna which will then follow and
he'll focus on lead politics within
Russia which of course are always
interesting and then Lincoln who is
really an expert on democracy promotion
and elections and protests generally
will try to open the discussion up to
bring some comparative insights into
into the Russian case and I will open up
the floor for discussion okay just to
begin let's see this is just the
official election results we can see
united russia just under the fifty
percent barrier the communist LDPR and
just russia down in the mid-teens and
then two minor parties patriots of
russia and right cause just barely
creeping over the the one percent marker
this is just the official results and
one thing that the number of observers
have pointed out is that the largest
drops for united russia were in some of
the big industrial cities if we look at
the ten regions with the largest decline
in votes for united russia we see lots
of the the big industrial centers
including Moscow and st. Petersburg olas
being especially well represented
including lorsque
of panem as well so what this suggests
is that the phenomenon by which United
Russia vote really fell the decline was
really concentrating a lot of the big
cities on which I think has big
implications for how Russia is ruled
given the importance of st. Petersburg
Moscow in the big industrial cities in
Russian politics and of course I like
this slide as well the three regions
where vote share increased the most
didn't think it was possible for the
vote to increase in Chechnya but it does
in this round all the way up from 99.4
to 99.5 okay now is a political
scientist it really warmed my heart to
see to see this particular a banner at
the protests Gauss of course it's a
famous statistician who came up with
this notion that you should be able to
detect aberrant behavior or behavior
that is very sophistical unlikely simply
by making lots and lots of measurements
and then and then adding them all up so
if you think about flipping a coin right
if you flip a coin a hundred times
sometimes it's going to be come up forty
percent heads and sixty percent tails
sometimes it's going to be vice versa
but on average you should go up to about
fifty percent right so if you do this a
hundred times we do this a thousand
times you should get this nice
symmetrical bell-shaped distribution and
if a similar notion can be applied to
the vote share in Russia and this is
just the vote share for different
parties in Russia and we can see that in
some districts for example the little
bit hard for me to see if I think this
is al dente errors is the tallest one we
can see that the vote average is right
around fourteen percent in some
districts it's lower in some districts
it's higher but on average so some
district it
oh this is not working okay well in some
districts is lower in some districts is
higher but on average the boats kind of
congregate around here and that's the
same for all love for that for the
economies of Russia the the scrabble you
gotta ASEA and then Jim Russkies part of
the Liberal Democrats but for United
Russia we see a very different
distribution and not only do we see that
we see these conspicuous spikes right
around the fifty percent margin that
really shouldn't be there if the results
had not been doctored also around the
fifty sixty seventy eighty percent
spikes we see these increases in vote
share for United Russia that if this
process were to happen without human
intervention we should not see those
spikes so it's very likely that vote
counters in particular districts where
the vote was forty-nine percent decided
you know 49-percent doesn't look so
great we got to get it up to 50 so and
that seems to happen continually
throughout the distribution so this
suggests that there was a lot of ballot
stuffing that went on on the day of the
election and there's been a lot of
attention paid to this but I but there's
a saying in election monitoring that
only amateur steal elections on Election
Day I think one of the things we need to
take into account is that the bigger
biases in the Russian electoral process
happened much earlier the biases and the
difficulty of opposition parties true
opposition parties to register limits on
access to the media and the bureaucratic
harassment of opposition figures okay so
we need to take these bigger picture
questions into account okay the protests
many people have pointed out that this
was very much a middle-class
mobilization that took place across
Russia on December 10th to protest the
widespread belief that there was fraud
in the parliamentary elections and the
effort was really driven in large part
by middle class urban the young the
successful and this is very important in
an interesting and very interesting I
think it's also important for example
that signal sub shock was there
in teaneck and alaki these for those of
you who don't know she's often called
the Paris Hilton of Russia and having
her there i think is important because
it demonstrates that it's cool at the
protest right she wasn't treated very
well during her during her appearance on
the stage but I think if I were in the
Kremlin I would be very worried that
figure opinion makers like this whether
you think very highly of sameness of
chalk or not but it's hard to say that
she's not an opinion maker particularly
among the young in Russia so having her
at this particular event I think would
make me a little bit worried so a lot of
people that have commented on this
notion that these were middle class
successful people protesting but I think
two points I think have been less well
recognized one is I think that there is
also a constituent constituency within
the government bureaucracy who are all
so young and frustrated by the lack of
upward mobility by the lack of
professionalism within the bureaucracy
so I think that there is if we for
example if we I just want to say that
this group of this constituency in
support of a more open political system
is not just a a private phenomena not
just a civil society phenomena I think
there are also lots of young
professionals within the Russian
bureaucracy who see this as a chance for
them to advance their own agenda and
their own career interests and if we
think about something like the the state
procurement process which Alexander
Navalny has turned into a real political
issue we have to remember that it was
bureaucrats within the state
administration that have initially put
the bids online so that someone like 'no
volley Navalny could take advantage of
them and there are other examples of
efforts within the bureaucracy I think
to promote a more reform agenda also I
think less attention has been paid to
the government's response to the protest
which I think has not been especially
coherent mr. Putin's initial remarks
blaming Hillary Clinton I don't think
went over very well his remarks on the
call-in show I think also many people
thought didn't really recognize the the
depth and scope of the opposition and
favorite example is on December 10th the
day of the protest an event that had
been well planned in advance that
everybody knew about when government
spokesman Dmitry Peskov was asked what
the government had to say about this
important event he said the government
is not prepared to comment at this time
so this kind of really suggests that
they were reeling from this and in some
sense this is understandable i think the
the events of december 10th really did
catch lots of people lots of analysts
off guard so it's not it's not
particularly surprising but it also
suggests that the possibilities for
creative solutions coming from within
the elite to address this for this
problem are unlikely okay where are we
now okay the presidential in the end the
end the future some people have argued
that the heightened awareness of the
cost of engaging oven of election fraud
which did obviously spark this big
protest and the fact that there might be
less need to engage in fraud in the
presidential election because mr. Putin
is more popular than United Russia and
if he's polling you know in the upper
40s the need for massive election fraud
is likely to be low so we might find at
the presidential elections will be
cleaner than the parliamentary elections
however we should also keep in mind that
the votes are very unpredictable in a
setting like this and I wouldn't be
surprised if a first-round victory
appears within reach or if there's a lot
of volatility in the polls that we do
see a lot of the same kinds of tactics
that we saw in the parliamentary
elections I think during the campaign
period such as such as it is we will see
the Prime Minister Putin resort to
emphasizing issues like anti-corruption
moderate nationalism and the spectre of
instability should he leave office these
are kind of standard
combin tactics during elections in
autocratic countries I think it's
important to point out that the two key
pillar of mr. Putin's rule especially
since 2004 high rates of economic growth
and high levels are personal popularity
are gone and aren't coming back I mean
that think that's the important if we
look at say growth rates from 2001 going
forward we have the financial crisis
which hits russia very hard in 2008-2009
but if we look at 2010 going forward we
see that the the trend is pretty flat
and economic growth and particularly if
the economic crisis in Europe continues
the outlook for Russian growth will be
much lower than it was in previous
periods which is never a good thing for
incumbents and as we look at mr. Putin's
presidential approval ratings I think
what we see is a long secular decline in
public support for for mr. Putin a lot
of people have no it said that the real
key turning point in public attitudes
towards mr. Putin was his decision on
sep tember 24th to to run for the
presidency and that this really outraged
a lot of people that might be true but I
think we also see a lot of Putin fatigue
setting in in that if we look from 2010
all the way down to the december two
thousand eleven we see really a pretty
stark decline from around seventy
percent approval rating to around forty
four percent of respondents expressing
trust in in prime minister putin it's
just very difficult for politicians to
stay popular for such long periods of
time eventually the people remember the
bad things a lot more than they remember
the good things what will happen after
the elections of course as debate leash
and Silva had a piece recently where she
predicted that after the elections
presumably that mr. Putin lwin which
appears very likely that the Putin
regime will be more autocratic there are
some reasons to think that is the case
the watering down of the ledges of
legislation on election of Governors
which seems to be happening the
appointment of mr.
Yvonne off and recently the well we'll
just leave it at that but of course it's
very hard to know what will happen after
the presidential election and I'm sure
Steve will tell us say a lot more about
that so I did all the easy part telling
you what already happened I'll leave it
to Steve to do the hard part of trying
to figure out what's going to happen in
lead politics and thanks a lot it's full
thanks Tim not for the assignment that
you gave me but I don't intend to
fulfill it so no problem I feel that I
want to talk about elite politics by
which I mean what happens within the
sort of what we sometimes call the
ruling circles but also the the
oligarchs the most prosperous and
influential circles in Russian society
and government about these people there
are things that we know and the things
that we don't know and a lot that we
don't know but let me say start off with
one thing that we do know and then turn
to some other interesting indicators in
the past few months as to what may be
happening within the within the elite
one thing we know about the elite is
they're very sensitive to polls and two
numbers like the ones that Tim put here
on the on the screen and he's absolutely
right that you saw a change in those
numbers well before September 24th and
people often pay attention to that
the top line the decline from 70 down to
44 in the space of three years but look
at the bottom line in that's the number
of people who have no confidence in
Putin and in 2008 that number was eight
percent really tiny it's eight percent
and in the second half of 2010 it jumped
up to twelve percent in the second in
the first half of 2011 it jumped further
to seventeen percent and in the third
quarter of 2011 it jumped up to 21 now
what you see is the number of people
prepared to say to pollsters that they
have no confidence in Putin went up two
and a half times in three years that's a
an important secular trend you want to
interpret that and Russian political
analysts did interpret it and I'm
relying here on an interesting analysis
done by Michelle Dmitry if the head of
the Center for Strategic Research he's a
former colleague of mine i should say
the carnegie endowment and he was at the
carnegie Moscow Center you will if you
google the Center for Strategic Research
and mica Demetria on or look for him on
YouTube you will find lots of
interesting material but his he and his
colleagues began putting forward a
number of conclusions last year about
and this is within the elite this is a
the Center for Strategic Research is a
government funded institution one mid
video if is not electable for another
term at two there's a potential for
major political upheaval and three the
middle class doesn't want revolution but
they're not worried about
stability they feel a secure foundation
has been created in Russian society the
Russian economy Russian politics that
should make it possible to have more
normal democratic practices okay that's
what we know of the results and of the
poll numbers that people were reacting
to this is perfectly widely available
what we don't know is how people what
they were thinking about this what the
conclusions they drew I'm reminded of a
colleague who a very sophisticated
Russian political commentator who for
years ago said not long before more than
four years ago not long before Putin
picked Medvedev she's this commentator
said there are many women influential
women commentators in Russia said mid
vaidya had already failed in the
primaries in the Russian elite somehow
some test of opinion had been set for
him and he hadn't passed it for
Americans is totally incomprehensible
what what what was this what were these
primers we didn't even know they were
taking place but he'd failed them except
that he won the vote of the one voter
who counted so a lot of what happens in
them in the elite is a mystery and yet
we have seen the most interesting
indicators in the past few months of
what's going on in the elite that I
think we shouldn't miss even as we
realize that a lot of this is still
mysterious I think we've seen
indications of a lot of discord a lot of
rethinking and we should watch that
space the most interesting one that
builds on the point Tim made about
disaffection within the government
bureaucracy has been the activity of
former finance minister and Deputy Prime
Minister Kudrin this is after all the
most respected influential member of the
Putin government the longest-serving
finance minister in Europe finance
minister of the Year by some rating
agency a couple of years back and what
does he do after he's fired in the fall
for expressing dissatisfaction with the
choice that had been made for between
Putin and Medvedev he's essentially
joined the protesters he now shows up at
the demonstrations he calls for a rerun
of the elections that's the most
provocative demand of the demonstrators
and it's supported by the ultimate
insider people used to say of Kudrin
that he was such a good friend of
Putin's that he would never get on the
wrong side of him we've seen him
disagreeing openly now offering to
mediate it's a little hard to understand
exactly what that means between the
protesters and the government but he's
not offering to mediate on the basis of
no opinions of his own he's offering
pretty radical opinions it said that he
is closely cooperating or consulting
with uh Natoli chu byes and his close
associate no blind
oceans for funding Alexander fellowship
if you know also people who have were
said to be never ready to get on the
wrong side of the authorities and yet
you see influential figures of the elite
now working for the thing that Putin
opposes the most which is treating these
elections as invalid you see the
comments of just two speaking another
insider and elite figure mr. Surcouf who
also has been moved to a new position
but before he did so gave an interview
in which he said the majority is really
the minority which is to say United
Russia which claims to be the party the
the dominant and ruling party and the
legitimate dominant ruling party is
really only one of a number of
contesting minorities and he said the
authorities are growing stupid before
our very eyes and three days later was
out of a job so you ask yourself what
what's going on you hear it said that
other oligarchs are stepping up to offer
their support whether its funding or
moral support to opposition parties to
particularly to the candidacy of mr.
prokhorov now mr. prokhorov is whether
he's an opposition figure is disputed
but what you see is different
expressions of elite dissatisfaction
with what's happening let me quickly end
with with two points here what are the
goals of these people in the elite who
are dissatisfied with what
how different are they from the
protesters I've said that on one crucial
issue that is whether the elections were
valid there's no difference between
Kudrin and and the people who have been
in the streets beyond this I think it's
a little more difficult to to say we can
only speculate and it's possible that
many people in the elite who are unhappy
with what has gone on who've been
perhaps answering pollsters that they
too don't like the fact that that
support for and they share this loss of
support that you see in the population
at large for the status quo it may be
that they have some disagreements maybe
they would be content with the return of
Putin as long as there were more checks
put on it either of an informal or a
constitutional kind how would those be
embodied maybe through the appointment
of figures in the government who were
not beholden to him a reformist prime
minister other cabinet members who are
committed to more radical members more
radical measures perhaps looser
restrictions on opposition political
activity the
the kinds of measures that President
Medvedev talked about last December when
he said there should be open
registration of parties or perhaps an
agreement that there will only be one
more Putin term and perhaps an agreement
that the new Parliament will only sit
for a year and you can begin to
speculate about this agenda this isn't
yet the sort of agenda that is out there
in the streets or as being that as far
as we know being negotiated behind
closed doors but it's on people's minds
let me finish with one thought about the
role somebody we hardly mention any more
played in this transformation and that's
President Medvedev himself who is now
treated as a kind of figure of fun in
Russian politics and who in many ways
deserves it he's not probably got even
though I think he said in the past
couple of days he might run for
president again probably not got the
brightest political future and yet I
think that he is tenure as president was
actually quite significant for the
emergence of this kind of elite
dissatisfaction and the opposition that
we've been talking about and the
normalcy that he was trying to suggest
he had brought to the presidency was it
of course a kind of phone or Mille see
and yet his tenure as president was
marked by relentless criticism of
putinism and that I think slowly began
to erode the restraints that people felt
in expressing their own dissatisfaction
with the status quo I think it removed
began and this was the result of many
other
as well but I think he made a little
contribution to it which we should
recognize began to erode fear in this
respect President Medvedev Putin's
experiment in choosing his successor
President Medvedev was only partly
successful his successor created an
environment or contributed to an
environment or certainly supported an
environment in which people were much
more ready to say they didn't like what
was going on and I think that view is
much more widespread than it used to be
in the elite and much more openly voiced
thanks thank you Steve Tim and Elise and
my colleagues at the Herman Institute
before I begin I just want to I'm not a
Russia expert so the kind of talk that
Steve just gave which I found very
interesting and very helpful for me is
not what you're going to get from me so
so you can take some moments and digest
these talk when to shift gears a little
bit I bring an outsider perspective and
in debt I'm really looking at this
through a comparative lens because
that's really the only lens I have for
understanding that these are these
events in Russia let me just and and
what comes to mind from from that
perspective when you think about it I'm
going to begin by talking about kind of
that perspective and then I'm going to
talk about what that might tell us about
what could happen next and then what how
my putin respond to that situation and
third what can we the United States do
so I'm gonna try to cover those four
points but the perspective which which
kind of unavoidably springs to mind is
this kind of electoral breakthrough
model which is in this region is known
also as the color revolution model and
let me just spend a little bit of time
discussing that so the color revolution
model depending on where you start has
its roots in Chile and the Philippines
in the 1980s and 90s but really
for the purpose of this region moves to
Serbia Georgia Ukraine and Kyrgyzstan
those four countries in that order from
2002 2005 where where these events
really got people to think differently
about political development in the
former Soviet Union to think differently
about what might happen in the former
Soviet Union do you think differently
about what elections and stolen
elections mean meant in the former
Soviet Union by two thousand four or so
people spoke frequently about the
electoral breakthrough model of
democratic development if you're working
in democracy assistance you were
expected to know about this and this was
kind of a standard model and the model
went something like there would be a
stolen election and it would be 12 and
the regime would try to steal one too
many elections people would get outraged
they would go to the streets and and
then if you remember I don't know how
many member Gary Larson the the American
cartoonist but he had a cartoon the
cartoon called the far side in the 80s
which was quite brilliant and he had
scientists on the Buddha board like this
and all the very complicated
mathematical claims on one side very
complicated mathematical equations on
the other side and in the middle is that
then a miracle happens and and that was
kind of the theory here then a miracle
happens and you have democracy and but
but there were other elements of that
electoral breakthrough model as it was
explained that that are worth keeping in
mind here one was a big part of that big
part of that miracle happening was the
fracturing of the political elites and
of the end of the ruling class and
obviously what Steve was talking about
earlier that really kind of brought that
to my mind in in all of those countries
today you know at that time today's
color revolutionary was yesterday's
political reformer from inside the
regime the color revolutions were not
led by outsiders they were led by
insiders former Prime Minister's former
speakers of parliament former justice
ministers former ambassadors under under
that government so so that was a very
important way of thinking about politics
and then three things happen right first
thing happened is that post-election
demonstrations and activities stop
leading to change so by 2005 you have
the color revolution which overthrew the
iliev regime in Azerbaijan and the
reason you haven't heard of that
because it failed and didn't happen in
2006 similar events with lukashenko in
Belarus which failed and didn't happen
so you have now this kind of evening of
the scales where sometimes the color
revolution model works and sometimes it
doesn't then 2010 in Kyrgyzstan followed
by 2011 in several countries in North
Africa you have what clearly are are
some kind of breakthrough of some kind
obviously a little premature and or just
wrong to call them Democratic
breakthroughs but they were not linked
to election so it began to think maybe
elections aren't the key part of that
miracle happening maybe we don't need
that so that on the left side of the
equation and then of course what
happened is we began to look at the
countries where the color revolutions
actually had occurred and we said hmm
maybe this doesn't have much do it
democracy right kyrgyzstan went quickly
back into being a semi authoritarian
regime Georgia became a different kind
of semi democratic regime that it had
been or in some people's eyes a semi
authoritarian regime and Ukraine you
know the couch mode shiancoe Yanukovych
direction of Ukrainian politics is
fascinating but it's not revolutionary
in that sense and what we've learned is
that when authoritarian or semi
authoritarian or semi democratic regimes
transition they often transition to more
of the same right the transition can be
kind of lateral as well as forwards or
backwards so so with that this is the
context in which i think these events
are occurring in russia which means that
expectations and whether you want to
call that optimism or pessimism ending
on where you sit should be tempered it
is also obviously none of us have it
released i don't have a crystal ball and
i don't know what will happen but there
are some we can look at both successful
and failed color revolutions and the
responses of leaders in that situation
and see at least some possibilities one
is liberalized and concede something
right say you know what we're going to
have elections for these local officials
or we're going to maybe get the media a
little more free or we're going to allow
people to have more freedom of
association whatever it might be the
second is ignore protests and hope they
go away right it's going to get chilly
so you in Russia or look people get
distracted will have you know the
Olympic or something but not you know
that's 2014 and the third is to crack
down right to arrest some people to bang
some heads to put some people in jail to
tighten the law
us right and we've seen if if you were
to guess which direction is Russia going
I would seems like that's the most
likely none of these are perfect right
liberalizing is very hard once you
liberalize you empower those reform
elements within your government who
become tomorrow's call the
revolutionaries you build social
movements bill they become stronger
people aren't just happy to have more
freedom they use that freedom right so
it's not a great way to stay in power
ignoring protests that's kind of a
high-risk stress there's no cost to it
but it's a high-risk strategy there's no
reason to think they're going to go away
especially in the particular case of
Russia there's another election around
the corner so so that seems like an
unwise strategy cracking down now this
is a very high stakes game right because
you put too many people in jail and
suddenly you have a full-scale
revolution on your hands however this is
the one that's been the most successful
this worked for the elite of regime in
2005 it worked for lukashenko in 2006
and 2010 and and most notably and often
forgotten where it worked the man I
think in the most clearly wasn't
Tiananmen Square in 1989 which was
almost a quarter century ago and has
bought the Chinese leadership and kept
them in Dina's help get them in power
one of the reno for another 25 years
having said all that and having said
that there are not a lot of easy options
here it is going to be tough for Putin
to put this genie back in the bottle I
wrote a piece on this called something
is happening and you don't know what it
is do you have mr. Putin I hope some of
you get the illusion something has
changed he can't go back you can't roll
this back so what do you do and looking
not just at the color revolutions but
looking at the events in North Africa
last year what can you do now I would
argue that there actually is a strategy
that that Putin can employ here not not
to guarantee anything but to increase
his chances and it's one that I've seen
elsewhere used in the former Soviet
Union in the last year or two most
notably i think in azerbaijan and the
lessons of the color revolutions were
clear and they were learned by nobody
better than Putin right who learned this
lesson which is don't allow these little
freedoms right these benign looking
international organizations actually can
be doing something right these did the
freedom of media that you allows you to
keep going to the foreign aid
come in can be or can be your undoing
right that was the lesson of the color
revolutions crackdown the lessons of the
Arab Spring just in shorthand is
different the lesson of the Arab Spring
is to govern better right not
democratized not liberalize but to
govern better and I would suggest that
that's the wisest thing that Putin can
do right now rather than liberalizing a
grant more media freedom maybe fight
some corruption maybe you have your have
your cronies feel a little bit less
money and put some money back into
building infrastructure now this
approach in my view also creates a very
big problem for the United States right
and we'd get to more of that in a second
but just for now the United States views
democracy and governance as to what's
the you know two parts of the same
project the two sides of the same coin
that good governance is both caused by
and leads to more democracy however
that's not always the case good
governance off good democracy often can
lead to better governance but the
reverse is not true right however all of
our all of our strategies are aimed are
better bet but it's easier to support
good governance it's easier to go to a
country and say we want you to obey laws
rather than we want you to have fair
elections so we're kind of set up that
when a country starts governing better
we see that as a sign they're
democratizing and we back off but but
it's often not a last option for Putin
which is not which is worth thinking
about is to create a distraction right
this is something that leaders do all
over the world when when things are bad
you distract and in a country that is
where the government relies on at least
to some extent some kind of nationalism
to keep it as the kind of ideology and
parenthetically has countries which they
which are neighbors which also rely on
very kind of hyper nationalist regimes
that and where there are disputes going
on between those countries this can be a
rather volatile situation right so it is
if you're sitting in the Kremlin right
now every day that people are talking
about elections is a bad one every day
that people are talking about Oh for
example Georgia is a good one right now
if you're sitting on in the new
chancellor in the new
presidential palace which the American
government built in Tbilisi every day
that people are thinking about elections
and this billionaire who can't run for
office because he's not really George
and even those last name is vanished
feeling he was born in georgia is a bad
one and every day that people talk about
Russia is a good one so so there is some
potential volatility there as well I'm
just going to end with this and I'm
going to be brief because I have to be
because I not much to say on this what
can or should the u.s. do right now and
before I attempt to answer that question
which I'm don't have to another an easy
answer I would just underscore that it's
important really it's the first half of
that question that matters what can the
u.s. do right now we can play the should
game a lot but what can a country do
right now that has demonstrated probably
decreasing returns on being able to
influence outcomes in that part of the
world a growing domestic sentiment
towards pulling back generally from from
being involved in the rest of the world
and don't have any money left
nonetheless it also as part of this it
is significant and a very good sign that
Putin's first reaction predictably and
probably wisely to some extent was to
try to make this about the u.s. right
those people were out there on the
streets because Hillary Clinton has some
nefarious plan rather than because the
Russian government stole election um to
the credit of the Russian people that
didn't really fly so that's good and
that suggested nited states might be in
a better position that then then our
most pessimistic thoughts would suggest
but there's still not a lot that we can
do in most of these breakthroughs
particularly the post called a
revolution when we've kind of been on
the sidelines in Kyrgyzstan in North
Africa and we've had a very limited
ability to influence these events right
we can send election monitors but
observing an election and determine
calling it unfair if the Russian
government lettuce and calling an
election unfair that everyone kind of
knows is unfair to begin with is not
making a huge contribution it can be
valuable but it's not a huge
contribution the laws and the structures
of Russia as well as the size and scope
of the country mean that this is not a
country we can dump you know three
million dollars into NGO development on
in a democracy field and have an outcome
in a year so
we are the United States and the West in
general is in a position where we don't
have a lot of ability to influence the
outcome okay before we turn to a
question and answer I just will pose a
question a broad question to each of the
speakers or a comment / question that
may help stimulate discussion during the
Q&A for Tim some of the data you showed
which was very helpful brings up this
question that many people have been
asking which is you know why are the
demonstrations happening besides the
short-term impetus of corrupt elections
and that question can be phrased more
specifically as is it a response to
economic conditions worsening economy or
is there a kind of long-term fatigue and
really this fatigue has just tipped over
the edge since Putin announced in
September and you know perhaps if it's
the latter could you comment maybe a
little bit about some of the other
developments if you think it's the
latter some of the other developments in
Russian politics such as the
environmental movement we had surely
cova here last fall and there have been
you know perhaps growing members of the
opposition and growing organization of
that opposition the emergence of Navalny
and so on for Steve Susannah vich that
was very interesting point about
Medvedev and I think very telling and I
never really thought about that before
that Madhvi out of you know has been
criticizing putinism and it just
wondered if you ever thought that the
cause of that might be a strategy that
Putin put in place meaning you know
there's opposition out there so maybe we
should try to move it away from myself
and moving on to med vieta of like he's
going to talk about the problems and
sort of acknowledge them and then we
won't really do anything about them so I
just wonder if that's the kind of but
perhaps more
longer-term strategy to have made via to
play that role or if you think that's a
his criticism in his more democratic
stance is something that he you know
personally believes in and that he was
actually interested in achieving the
goals and then for Lincoln I guess this
comment is about yours various
strategies that the regime could take in
response they are all interesting but I
wanted to talk about the create a
distraction one especially I think
that's in a way what Putin has been
trying to do especially recently
certainly with criticizing Hillary
puttin although that Hillary Clinton
that might have been a that would make
her nervous that might have been a sort
of knee-jerk response I kind of you know
we've got to go criticize the Americans
and it didn't fly but more recently we
see the criticism of Mike McFaul on the
evening news so I wonder if there is a
kind of coordinated response to place
blame on Americans order to try to you
know play that card of of labeling the
US as a meddling troublesome superpower
and then finally with regard to the same
issue perhaps Putin's recent speech in
which he talked about the danger of
nationalist separatism which seems
ridiculous initially like why is he
talking about that national separatism
is not on the agenda and if it is it
would be coming from Chechnya and
basically if it came from Chechnya
that's his fault because he gave so much
power and autonomy to the Chechen leader
currently so what is he talking about is
he just kind of feeling around for
things that he's personally nervous
about does he truly believe that or
maybe he believes that once the regions
are the ethnic republics notice this
essential state is weak that they will
make a move again so perhaps he you know
that's a genuine fear which certainly
could be the case on Putin's part right
so
about national separatism and in the
same speech he talked about migrants and
he came up with some very you could say
stringent or possibly illegal policies
of registering registering migrants or
internal migrants in cities and that
seems just like a clear case of populism
we're kind of playing to people's fears
so it seems that those are some evidence
for your your third third or fourth
strategy and I just wondered if you had
any comment about that great first I
can't thanks others are really really
good comments predicting protests is a
really difficult thing to do in part
because if I could predict it so good
lucky melody Minaj and probably he would
be in the position to make them not
happen so it's not surprising that we're
almost always surprised by
demonstrations that that tip over from
these very heroic examples of
individuals who are protesting and
bearing high costs and then Lincoln's
miracle happens and everybody realizes
hey I feel the same way and look
everybody else feels the same way so
we're all going to go into the streets
together I'm not a big fan of arguments
that Facebook change the world and that
you know 1989 there are a lot of people
on the street they even before mark
zuckerberg was even born yet he was born
then but maybe just barely so he is not
a necessary condition but I think in
this case what what Facebook did is it
you had this counter and people could go
to the counter and see all the people
that were committed or said publicly
that they were going to go to the
demonstration on below they upload on
December 10th so i think that helped
people reveal information that they and
people like them felt the same way and i
think that did have a role in spurring
people too
Oh to go to the square so I don't think
that the protests were a response to the
economy the the secular decline and
growth that I talked about is it will
make it difficult Ainge the formula that
mr. Putin will need in his we call this
the second term the third term or the
fourth term I don't know if he comes
back as Marcus fourth the third to the
fourth or ever you legalistic you would
like to be so I do think that it that
the the state of the economy will play a
bigger role in constraining mr. Putin
and it will embolden people to criticize
if I don't think they had much to do
with the protests and one person that we
haven't talked at all about is somebody
let's see so each other you turn the
screen off okay well this is what any
way we can leave is mr. Novotny who has
become in some way the unofficial leader
should we say about these demonstrations
and he's a very interesting character
and we can we can talk more about him
but I don't want to steal the floor but
i do want to recommend one thing is if
you want to gain some insight into his
psyche go to his twitter page or to his
life journal of page and his avatar for
those of you who've seen it is to sumo
wrestlers one with his hands on the
throat of the other so this is clearly a
kind of macho guy who really trying to
adams to beg of you you you can't all
say maybe at some point we could river
when you can flip it back on just for
your pure a little bit of eye candy
so I do think this is in some ways and
also basically his livejournal and his
Twitter are something that you should be
following because there's lots of
interesting stuff on there very recently
there was a debate between him in a
Coonan where they had a very interesting
debate on nationalism in Russia so this
is his avatar that he chose as his
symbol for to announce who he was to the
world for those before we turn the floor
over this is why people comparing to
violates of Boris Yeltsin you know you
can sort of see Yeltsin doing that to
another guy and enjoying it on the
question of whether Medvedev was just
doing what Putin instructed him to do to
allow a kind of safety valve for
unhappiness to show a modern face to the
regime you know we don't know what these
guys talk about so we can't rule it out
and certainly Putin didn't act
vigorously to put a stop to it and that
I suppose could be considered a kind of
evidence that he acquiesced saw the
point but he might have acquiesced
unhappily because he might have
recognized two things that I would say
about this strategy if it was indeed his
strategy and Putin is not a dumb guy so
I would say if I can figure it out he
can figure it out one is the criticisms
were pretty harsh they didn't say
putinism is bad but they said almost
everything else that you could about the
system
and to my mind that was very bracing and
but had to be kind of radicalizing the
second thing I would say about it is
that the strategy was contradictory yes
it suggested that the regime had a
modern face that it was led by people
who had an awareness of how things ought
to work and the right direction for a
progressive reform um but if there were
no results the modern response is to get
mad right and the opposition did get mad
to my mind Navalny is the result of this
strategy if Putin thought there was
going to be some other results we should
have a talk with him as to what made him
think that was going to work okay yeah
so just a response hello just to respond
to Elise's question um I think you're
right i think the Hillary Clinton remark
is as much a strategy as it's just kind
of a knee-jerk think that they say um
and and it is probably the treatment of
Mike McFaul probably falls into that a
little bit as well however in your
question you refer to the US does he
just trying to portray the US as a
meddling troublesome superpower if
you're sitting the Kremlin the u.s. is a
meddling troublesome superpower I me
that that's pretty straightforward and
and that's been something that as much
as anything seems to have you know
really just on a very kind of personal
level and not without good reason
bothered Putin for a long time so Mike
who is a different kind of ambassador
who has this kind of strong background
in democracy work to go over there the
timing of this is either very good from
the US side or perhaps a very bad from
from the from from the Russian sides and
it just kind of exacerbates itself um I
think with regard to the second part of
your question look nationalism is the
obvious card that you play if
a regime that that's based on no real
other ideology and and these are just
various ways to play that out to explore
to feel out what's going to fly the best
do we blame do we mobilize people around
the regime because we scare them that if
not the other parts of the country are
going to are going to start becoming
separatists or do we try to find some
kind of easy scapegoat the Margaret
workers so those seem to me to be almost
trial balloons and we'll see a few more
trial balloons maybe we'll see a lot
more because maybe nothing will will
catch but it's that would be my enough
great thank you thank you we'd like to
open it up now so please just raise your
hand if you have any questions it's
right behind you I own dr. pol nur and
president of cinema verite and my
question is for everybody really is that
all of you have done have stated some
very interesting things but it may very
well be as was noted suggesting that you
mentioned the eye of spring the Arab
Spring may very well lead to with
Islamic state and democracy may in the
end turn into what is not our idea of
democracy same thing in Russia where
Putin is probably going to win again as
everybody has stated what's to stop him
after he has one potentially for another
eight years to create another little an
incident blaming the Chechens an attack
on a theater in Moscow or what have you
beating the head or whether however you
calls it and then everybody says off
instability is back that's why we need
Putin thank you yeah let's take of yet
let's take a few questions and mo have
the panelists okay respond please
introduce yourself Michael Rivkin
president emeritus association for the
study of nationalities there is one item
which was not discussed I think
extremely important is a
they're all of the three parties which
are in the parliament because I have
seen already graphics coming from Moscow
the calculating the results of this
election parliamentary election if
without cheating discounting the
cheating that shows the two parties the
calmness and the National Liberal
Democrats would have gotten the majority
now is this desirable outcome for the
Liberals is this not the situation of
the Muslim Brotherhood's in Egypt this
is a think something which you should
discuss one more question over here
unlike anywhere else the question is how
much our sliders have given words of
Russian government we know that recently
we have United States is now getting
closer to China and Russia might be more
you know isolated vector so to what
extent EU and US has really have tools
or potential for administration will be
holding national yeah sure I'll start on
not yeah I think we've seen incidences
already of signs being sent that
instability will be the inevitable
result of a weakening of mr. Putin's
position and this is again a tried and
true strategy of non Democratic leaders
and and Democratic leaders as well
doesn't matter when they're when they're
when they're threatened politically is
to say look things going to be a lot
worse without me and you'll be glad
you'll be sad that I left the stage I
think in this case though one group for
example that might have been counted on
to be afraid of instability r is the
investor community but I'm not sure
that's the case I think they see a lot
of the costs and the instability of
dealing in Russia even with the current
government for example if governors were
to be elected and kind of free and fair
elections I hardly think investors would
be upset by that they would probably
support that although from some circles
that might be the same as into
introducing some level of instability in
the system so in on the notion of who
would come to power in a free and fair
election in Russia of course I think
it's very dangerous to draw I think it's
potentially problematic to draw
conclusions based on what is really a
truncated sample of parties that were
allowed to compete in this election so
we really don't know what would happen
if you opened up the floodgates to all
parties and maybe you'd have you know
three or four nationalist parties or
three or four left-wing parties or three
or four maybe there'd be one left-wing
party we really don't know what would
happen in a free and fair election in
Russia it's also a problem with
interpreting approval ratings for a long
time we've heard the approval ratings of
mr. engage of mr. Putin were very high
but that's a very different choice than
an election where you have a choice
between two people you might prefer you
might like mr. Putin and approve of him
but you might prefer somebody else even
more and once you introduce a campaign
where people are allowed to criticize
and to you know think how volatile a
Republican primary has been or politics
can be so I'm sure that that you know
the calculations are done right and it's
very likely that you know nationalist
party would do well a communist party
would too well but I think there's a lot
more uncertainty in in in what would
happen in a future election if it was a
really free and fair election and can i
pick up on that Tim because I think it's
an important important question I agree
with what tim has said but i'd add a
couple of points one is that it if
people are in fact genuinely afraid that
if there's no space created for a
legitimate Democratic opposition then
you in fact do get a radicalized
opposition and you get a greater risk of
instability and that's why people like
Mikhail Dmitri of whom I was quoting at
the beginning of my talk are saying that
the survival of a democratic regime
depends on allowing an outlet for
parties that have been kept out of
politics they're saying it's a very
risky strategy to try to have the only
opposition in parliament be the
Communists and the Nationalists and I
think they're right about that and I
think they're getting much more of a
hearing the second thing I'd say is yes
whenever you have a political change
over of the kind that may be in store
here if you were looking at a
significant move toward some kind of
coalition government say some
instability results from that that's
what that's what political transitions
are about but the issue is who's
responsible and how big will how
significant will that instability be I
think the argument to come back to my
topic that the is getting more of a
hearing in the elite
is you need to have a strategy for a
soft landing or else you're going to
have a hard landing for non Democratic
leaders it's very important to get the
right opposition and much of the
political work you do is to make sure
that that's the right opposition it's
very important to finish a second you
get seventy percent of the poll of the
vote in a presidential election and you
be the Liberal Democratic reformer who
the West likes 7230 you're going to have
some problems if you beat the old
communist or the radical nationalist no
one in the West is really did that upset
about it similarly imagine if the poll
results aren't up there now but imagine
if the party's coming in second and
third were Democratic Western leaning
parties you have a very different
response so much of the good and the
good i'm not talking value good but the
successful political work done by the
Putin government over the last decade
and to make sure that these are the
parties that will come in second and
third the the problem that creates for
the West in the extreme case is in
situations precisely like Egypt where
what if you have the right opposition
you can and you're not a Democrat you
can still get support from the West the
problem is you can't always get support
from your people and at the end of the
day that's what brings down a Mubarak in
Egypt I don't think we're necessarily
there yet with Russia at all but that is
that is that is the that's the problem
that that Putin ultimately will will
will confront um as far as what's to
stop him from from cracking down look he
can crack down that's very much an
option that's out there I kind of laid
that laid that out he can make up that
distraction he cannot make up that
distraction it doesn't matter but
cracking down when you're at seventy
percent the polls and really control the
media is very different than cracking
down when you're at 45 and fifty percent
of the polls and you know there's
various other media and other ways of
communicating with voters and that
becomes instead of making yourself more
stable it begins to undermine that
stability that's the dilemma which which
the Putin regime now faces and that's
why the easy option isn't isn't isn't
necessarily there
it's interesting we might think of
whether we'll get boonton return of
Putin 2002-2003 where he did work fairly
successfully with a broad range of
groups within Parliament to help
legislation get past or the the Putin of
the kind of 2005 to 2008 period where he
arguably didn't need to do that but he
didn't did anything can I just had one
thing on this question of a crackdown as
I think it's it's a kind of principle
unstated although sometimes stated of
the Putin regime that while this may be
a chronic rule it's not going to be
bloody and it's one thing to shed a lot
of blood against a Chechen opposition
that you can say is terrorist violent
and supported by al-qaeda and that is
blowing up apartment buildings in in
Russian cities it's another thing to
shoot Democratic demonstrators and I
don't think there's a lot of confidence
in the regime that you could get
soldiers and policemen to do that in
fact it would really be a desperation
move that would that could be the end of
the legitimacy of the Putin regime I
think they're desperately afraid of
needing to resort to bloodshed
come to the mic please come to the mic
so we can hear you better right you can
take three at once so through the water
hi Natalia Pella man of democratic
Russia committee first of all a small
amount announcement if I may there's
going to be a protest in support of the
Russian opposition on the fourth of
februari by the Russian consulate which
is east 91st street at twelve o'clock
noon so if anybody's interested please
do come as you know there is a
demonstration in Russia on the fourth of
Highbury and my question is if on the
fourth of March let's say Putin wins in
the first round and on a fifth there is
a mime type situation as in protesters
begin to camp out hundreds maybe
thousands what do you think the outlook
for that is and first firstly and
secondly how would the west and America
specifically react to that thank you we
have a few pointers jumping with that
such an easy question
okay I tell mom Brewster a diplomat in
residence at City College if you could
expand on the remarks by your colleague
Dmitri trenin in Moscow from the
Carnegie Institute that ambassador
McFaul could be one of the best
ambassadors ever or he could be a
complete disaster and the difference
will be very slight what is the
difference what what does he need to do
to be successful she said that she is so
themselves to a 1930s insular and they
would cling to rigid ideology and
Russian ways party open it up to your
concerns of economic integration or
relationship and do you think that that
they're aware of this i mean in terms of
you know
the importance of opening up politically
that might in turn influence their
economic policy you know because they're
afraid I imagine they're afraid and
economic slowdown right now that quite
strong terms powerful but yes I'm going
to start with the question that Mike
McFaul then I'll move on to the first
question I think to a large extent Mike
the success or failure of this
ambassador will have a lot to do with
things that are kind of out of his hands
how this plays out in Russia I think so
sort of that extent I don't I don't feel
it's appropriate think is doing a good
job but I don't want to get into the
nitpicking he's only been there a few
weeks but how this plays out if if if
there's a democratic breakthrough Bassin
irmak fall and the Obama administration
will be poised like the rooster to take
credit for the sunrise and I'm hoping
that is the outcome but if not if there
is a souring of relationships it will be
very easy to point at an ambassador who
is not afraid to speak his mind on some
of these issues um with regard to your
question which I take it as a two-part
question one do you think this could
happen and secondly what would be the
reaction the West if it did happen so
let me try to take those two pieces the
first half of that and this is where I
defer to my Russia expert colleagues is
it is important to have something to
mobilize around right so who is so in
Ukraine it was Yushchenko right he
became the person that it was a very
clear one race in the country was very
divided if that begins to emerge not
that it has to be a 49 49 race but if
that begins to emerge where there is a
feeling that some other Canady there had
the election stolen from from him or her
or was treated so egregiously unfairly
that you can mobilize around that
notably in Georgia for example the main
demands of the opposition parties were
simply that the saakashvili's departed
national movement all they wanted to was
be in first place which they got more
votes and everybody else that was not an
unreasonable demand and Sonya's party
that they break too
seven percent threshold the exit poll
showed them around eight to ten percent
and the return show them around five
percent I was told by i was there i was
at the time working closely with these
guys and i was told by senior people in
both parties that if the chevre nods and
government agreed to that they would
have just called off the demonstrations
but they couldn't get people on the
streets with that demand for the demand
they switched to was the resignation of
chvre nozzle which they admitted to me
was just let me to get people to the
streets everyone knew that Chevy would
never resign in 2003 but but the answer
to that is that is that there has to be
something to mobilize around I think a
little bit more than just another stolen
election what will happen and what will
the u.s. do this is an intriguing
question not least of which is because
that it will occur I think it means
another question but I think after the
Republican nomination has been wrapped
up by a smart and kind of in that sense
not nutty which makes my minority and
his party but not nutty candidate who is
given to rather hawkish views on foreign
policy and I'm speaking of Mitt Romney
if it's Gingrich even more extreme where
what will happen is that you'll have in
the middle of a close presidential
election them in march eight months out
in america that counts as the middle
will be a government in Washington that
has to actually think about policy and
think about even though their hearts and
certainly the ambassador's heart might
be let's go all in with the Democrats
there are political things to be
considered there are you go on with the
Democrats you might get some other
problems in other parts of the world and
the small D Democrats in Russia I mean
but a Republican opponent who will be in
turn as internal polls trailing and
knowing that and will see this as an
opportunity to take stake out a position
beating on this very common Republican
mean that the United States has
abandoned its its friends because we no
longer you've any foreign assistance to
countries like Israel or Georgia right
I'm joking um but but so so it will
become a policy with which a a Romney
campaign can run and with no risk
because just like just as McCain took a
very hawkish this not Georgia during the
George
Russia war because he had to do
something to shake up the race a little
bit so that that will how it will affect
the political dynamic the United States
which will likely push the Obama
administration to do more than it
otherwise might like again the question
is what can it do write these this is a
big country and this is a big country
that that unlike say Ukraine is not a
battleground between Russia and us for
influence because Russia's the country
so it's it makes it much much tougher
you can I just add one thought to this I
I think you're pointing toward a real
problem for the protesters which is how
to keep going how to keep the size of
the crowds increasing februari forth
will be a test of that can they get a
significantly bigger size crowd than
they got on december twenty fourth and
if they do what do they do after that
and what do they do on March fifth the
the political strategies for continuing
mobilization are that's their big
question right now and whether they can
find a way to do it we don't know but I
would say if they the demonstrations do
keep growing and there is a real
momentum here that if they really are
tapping into popular feeling that
extends beyond the Ring Road in Moscow
then the course of events is not going
to depend very much on the West's
reaction here I disagree with link in a
little bit I think this is overly
intricate about the United States we're
going to be as the United States always
does in such situations playing catch-up
that was the American response on August
that was the American response in Tahrir
Square and the real center of the action
will be between the people and the
people in people on the streets and the
people in power and the the Western
governments will be positioning
themselves nervously trying not to get
too out far out front that won't be a
risk and not to keep too far behind he's
not asking because security other
protesters one of them will very much
depend on how West will react because I
personnel sorry buddy I personally
disagree that luton his
art or actions I don't think personally
we hesitate to use force it will be
other aspects of you know the other
factors that will stop thank you very
much I'm just very briefly I think one
problem that the opposition does have is
that they don't have among the current
candidates anybody that they would rally
around to say geez we really would
rather have zoo gone off he was just
really cheated out of this election
areas and really much rather have him in
place so that's going to be a challenge
for the protesters on the other hand as
you mentioned before these are two
elections in fairly close proximity and
if some of the same issues come up again
oh you might expect it's unreasonable to
expect a similar kind of response on the
other hand if mr. Putin is still polling
in the in the mid-40s and if he is able
to win particularly win in the first
round without there being a widespread
perception of vote fraud then brinda
protesters I think are really in a
really in a difficult place something I
mean this is this is you know correct i
want to underscore how important that
the not having that person might be but
also the difference in a parliamentary
in a presidential election right a
parliamentary election there's always a
little bit of election fraud and you can
make as big in in countries where we
support the government in power testing
only ten percent of the votes the
official position of the election
reports are always it's a step forward
and the render and the views of the
people are respected if we don't support
that government empower it's called
election fraud presidential elections
are different it's a zero-sum game you
have to make a compelling argument not
that Putin stole himself from 49 to
seventy percent to make up some numbers
but that he stole the actual election
and in a reasonably free and fair
election the other person would have
that's a much higher bar so in fact you
may there may be some movement at if
there are you know the particular the
demonstrations aren't enormous I said
look we have to move on here this this
person one you know I just want to i'll
raise one small dissent here which is
this we don't really know what the
dynamic of popular opposition is going
to turn out to be some growing number
and its already large people in Russia
think that this rigged arrangement in
which Putin is able to win by keeping
out a legitimate opponents is something
that just drives them nuts and does that
turn out to be strong enough motivation
for an ongoing political campaign of
opposition to the regime we don't really
know one quite in Booley might actually
be interested to hear people's views on
the first round VERSE win versus a
second round what could the incumbents
try really hard in these kinds of
situations to avoid that second round
because that situation is very
unpredictable particularly if there is a
lot of sense that the opposition is was
was cheated in some way so I I mean but
for example including pro could of India
in the election who's the candid ease
most likely to steal votes from right
it's not Zhuge enough it's not
janoski it's probably Putin right so if
the goal is to win on the first round
that that seems to me to be a little bit
odd maybe the notion is that broken up
comes in third and then throws his
support behind Putin because we really
don't want to sue gone off maybe that's
the idea but it does seem to me to make
a second a first-round victory a little
bit more difficult to achieve again not
not knowing much about Russia I mean
there is the Ukraine precedent you don't
want to have that second round yeah that
that does that Kenan but that was
different because it was so close in the
first round as well um the Georgia 2008
president a precedent is different there
the president didn't want the second
round because we perceived the sign of
weakness even though even though it
would have cleaned up in the semi and
actually won by a much more resounding
margin um in Russia you also you know
it's reminded of when Edwin Edwards ran
against David Duke and the Democratic
Party made bumper stickers and said
those for the crook it's important oh
it's it's you know if if you get that
runoff against the best place we're
going to be is having a run off with
someone who is just more despised than
he and if he can set that up without all
the pitfalls along the way I don't think
he can that would be the best thing yeah
actually I wanted to just you your
question very quickly to about Europe
and what happens in Europe you there's
been debate okay yeah yes so so the the
I mean issue is if you're up goes south
this will just make it that much more
difficult for Putin to govern going
forward because growth will be harder to
achieve the approval ratings that were
high are not going to be what they were
and particularly if he wins on a sudden
in a second round well then that the
formula for governing looks very
different so in some sense people have
said well will the presidential
elections in change Russia Russian
politics in some sense they already have
I mean that you know that this room is
full i think is testament
to the interest in the topic which I
think if we would have poll if we would
have had this event for months ago and
asked everybody will you come to this
event on january 26 the turnout would
have been a lot lower ex ante and not
knowing what was going to happen after
the parliamentary elections so there was
one of them do you not understand it we
were busted oh yeah hey that's right and
all your pay will be docked unless you
show okay maybe we have time just a
small are we going oh we are Mindy's he
was being evicted from her space
until march six yeah clever I think
actually supporting election monitoring
in a variety of ways is one of the
things that the that the West can do
that Gullas support has come from a lot
of western donors a governmental and
non-governmental as well as from russian
donors and there are various kinds of
assistance then can be provided they you
were giving us some some graphs here oh
yes suggesting what what the nature of
you know how to document a manipulation
of elections you know a lot of that is a
partnership of Western and in Russian
and analysts but creating the capability
not for this election but in the future
for parallel vote tabulation for more
significant exit polling those are
non-interfering mechanisms that do make
it possible for people to have
confidence in their election seems to me
a very worthy sort of support I thank
everyone for coming and keep a look out
for the title of our unknown title of
our next talk maybe after the elections
in March